success is something which has to be
planned planned you gotta have a plan
plan I have to make some more plans plan
plan plan planning everybody stop
talking now attention I told you all of
my critics I've told you all that I was
the greatest of all time wanna beat
Thunder listen I told you today I'm
still the greatest of all time never
again defeat me never again say that I'm
gonna be defeated never again that make
me then the dog until I'm about 50 years
old then you might get me but I didn't
dance I didn't dance for a reason I
wanted to make him lose all his power I
kept telling me he had no punch he
couldn't hit he's swinging like a [ __ ]
he's missing let me see you box I hadn't
started dancing yet you can't say my
legs are going you can tell was tired
because what happened I didn't dance
from the cycling around oh I stayed on
the ropes when I stay on the ropes you
think I'm doing bad but I want all boxes
to put this on the page of boxes stay in
our homes is a beautiful thing with a
heavy weight when you make him shoot his
best shots and you know he's not hitting
you I will gave George home with two
rounds a steady puncher because that's
the day he was mine success is something
which has to be planned and success is
something which has to be earned in
advance true there is such a thing as
luck but just remember that luck is
something you can create for yourself if
you know the rules and follow them just
as I give them to you remember too that
success in the higher brackets of
achievement is something that can be had
only by taking others along with you and
the best definition of success which I
know is this success is the knowledge
with which to get whatever you want from
life
without violating the rights of others
and by helping others to acquire it when
you develop your business plan don't be
afraid to write everything down
everything that comes into your mind
because ultimately if you have a good
business plan well-thought-out
well-designed carried out for a year or
two or three you can start to follow
that
in an orderly fashion does it always
work it doesn't always work it doesn't
always turn out the way you think it's
going to turn out
you like the stumble or trip or falling
a goalie but if you have the plan you
can get up and continue on your path you
gotta have a plan everybody's got a
dream
everybody's got a goal what's the plan
and your plan has got to have something
I call the c5 complex your plan has got
to be clear concise compelling
consistent and committed you've got to
have a plan and when you're trying to do
something that you're truly passionate
about there is no plan B okay Plan B
sucks alright okay so it's as simple as
that you gotta have a plan I mean think
about that for a second three examples
Michael Jordan won six NBA championships
with the Chicago Bulls because he was
committed to plan a not plan B Oprah
Winfrey became the queen of all media
because he was committed to plan a not
Plan B whatever your politics are Barack
Obama is sitting in the White House
because he was committed to plan a not
Plan B okay Plan B sucks you should make
the assumption when you make an
investment there's some probability
you'll lose it it'll go to zero and
that's why you need to have you know a
reserve like a back-up plan some cash
set aside that if everything blows up
you're okay I find it extraordinary when
people make their first you know
liquidity event and they have some
capital that they blow it all again that
is the biggest mistake you've got to
take a nut even if it stays in cash or
it's a very very liquid safe security to
say that I don't touch it goes back to
what my mother taught me spend the
interest never the principle I mean look
you know I make a lot of crazy
investments I don't touch the principal
do you have a blueprint for your career
not a blueprint a cleanse but an actual
blueprint yeah I've always been one of
those weird kids were like when I would
go to high school I would like
make lists of like all the things that I
wanted to do and then it kind of like
check them off like a serial murderer
like did I do this and do this and do
this and when I went to college I like
assessed what I thought was like cool to
accomplish and then I like checked it
off like I've never been just like one
like live for the moment and who cares
what happened like c'est la vie like I
was never that I was highly organized
and so I think when I was younger this
is one of the cooler things about my
life and I have to acknowledge it
sometimes because when I like get mad at
it being humid or whatever that I was I
am living my life stream like the job I
have now I had a plan up until now which
was to get my own television show that I
would create and so I have to start
thinking more unless like unless I die
so I could die I could die this week or
something would that be that would be
pretty dramatic and cool but I barring
that I have to make some more plans so
now I'm looking at when I'm like oh I
should maybe have kids get married maybe
that sort of thing I should do that now
plan for both good and bad luck and part
of what it is is people say what do you
mean plan for good luck you know I have
this idea you know
it works out and then I and then things
keep going well good luck actually comes
in opportunities that you don't you
don't normally you don't normally see so
for example PayPal started as a
encryption on mobile phones company
because it was too close friends of mine
I joined the board when they found it
even though I thought encryption
technology and mobile phones back in
December 9 ta twas a was a not a good
idea which I told them but it was kind
of like you also back people and then
they were like well okay not not
encryption mobile phones maybe cache
some old phones or maybe not just cash
some old phones maybe cash on Palm
Pilots
maybe cash on Palm Pilots and peanut
service to the web and then they
launched with that and for the first
week they said well all this growth is
is coming through eBay but that's not
really what we planned we planned on
people like bringing their Palm Pilot
around with them exchanging money you
know these aren't our customers we
should
how to get them off and then of course
part of PayPal's great strength was
being able to pivot fast and then went
oh oh no these are our customers all the
rest of that stuff doesn't work this is
this is the thing that we need to go to
and that's an instance of what I think
of as planning for good luck which is
you basically you go okay sometimes what
happens when you start the journey of
going down to companies you're looking
for an opportunity that you may not
recognize Eve started it but then
suddenly you kind of you know like the
pioneering parallel you come around the
corner and all of a sudden there's new
opportunities available to you and that
you head very strongly to that and so
good luck is not just oh look my plan
worked
it's you will encounter opportunities
that you will need to move quickly and
grow into an exploit by having been on
the journey now planning for bad luck is
unfortunately a little bit more
straightforward which is sometimes you
find yourself you know pioneering going
that you can't find a way through the
mountains how do what a year what's your
plan B right and one of the ways that I
frequently think about this is I kind of
have a plan a a plan being a plan Z the
plan a is okay this is what we're think
you're doing Plan B is well if that's
not working what are my parameters of
flexibility I'm still trying to get to
that's the same you know build the same
product the same product market fit I'm
still trying to get there but maybe if I
try this rather than that and so for
example when I when I when we launch
LinkedIn you know our hope was that
people would just invite each other and
and the invitations would work and it
would grow in a big network and and you
know and that that would be all we need
to do in order to grow the network well
as it turned out we launched the network
and you know and a couple weeks later
we're growing at 2,000 people a week and
I was like wow that's not fast enough
so what were the other ideas we had in
mind the kind of plan B and the plan B
was well actually if we one of the
questions that people most have when
they come to LinkedIn is who else do I
know who's here so why don't we build an
address book utility that allows them
people to say okay how do I quickly find
out who else do I knows here upload my
address book I see use here we invented
that whole pattern
and that caused our growth rate to go
from like two thousand a week to like I
think it was about like twenty thousand
a week right so and that's you know
without that I don't know if we would
have succeeded maybe other Plan B's
would have worked and then plan Z is
what happens when it's just not working
at all right it's kind of a lifeboat
plan and that's part of the how you you
plan for both good and bad luck always
have a plan B so remember and this is
all census data the average
multimillionaire in the US has seven
different sources of income so that
means they have Plan B's all the time so
there's never a question like okay if
that was not working like I had a
business that I invested in a lot of
money recently and it wasn't working but
I have Plan B's I have like the seven
other Plan B's so I'm able to say okay
this is bringing me down every time I
talk to you guys I'm not gonna talk to
you anymore unless you have something
good to say to me and I could drop big
they could kick and scream but you put
all this money in I'm like okay I'm done
with that I have Plan B's so all the
time think about how many Plan B's
notice when I had a job at HBO I had a
plan B I had a cut before I left my job
at HBO I had my company running on the
side for 18 months before I left
full-time I had a dozen employees at my
company so always have the plan B's and
then it's easy to leave early in every
situation now again you don't have Plan
B's and relationships there's other
things there you have to be careful of
but
you know that's another talk the way
that we operate as a company you know
especially in don't go t is like what I
said we have a vision the vision will
have a strategy of how we're going to
achieve the vision which we do normally
over a period of five years you know I
mean like today we know why were going
even this investment that I announced of
100 million dollars here I didn't just
sit down on my own and just say it it is
part of our strategic plan to invest in
Kenya yeah I think that the best advice
I could give everyone is don't listen to
advice but if you are going to listen to
advice then making sure you actually do
something is a good advice if you just
sit around planning something and not
doing it you're not actually gonna get
to know everything thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know which of the clips meant
the most to you and how do you make
plans as an entrepreneur leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon